about this yes because there is a big
online rumor that you are going to play
Sue storm in the Fantastic Four film now
where does the rumor like this come from
apparently if you go to lunch with
somebody that is also in the industry
and you then start working together
according to the internet oh so you went
out with the director of Fantastic Four
what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and for those of you who might not have
want Mila Kunis to play Sue storm in the
MCU well it looks like you're probably
going to be happy now the reason I say
probably is because Mila Kunis has
denied and straight up said she is not
in the Fantastic Four film however we
have heard this before which is why I
say probably not 100 remember when Paul
Rudd said that he wasn't Ant-Man so from
an Commander Ant-Man was oh that's all
rumor man sorry things
and do you remember when Andrew Garfield
said that he wasn't the werewolf and he
wasn't in Spider-Man no way home well
Mafia where I'm like I'm not the
werewolf I promise you I am not the
werewolf and everyone's like you're the
werewolf you're the werewolf look at him
he's like he's doing this yeah so just
saying just because they say they're not
doesn't actually mean they're not
however in this case I don't actually
think Mila Kunis is going to be playing
Sue storm like she said she did meet
with the Fantastic Four's director the
upcoming movie that is Matt shackman and
this definitely sparked a lot of
conversation around her being in the
Fantastic Four movie as Sue storm now
again she still might be playing Sue
storm in the Fantastic Four she could
just be we won't call it lying because
well she has no choice if she is too
storm she can't come out and say it on a
talk show we'll just say that she's
hiding it if she actually is but she
seems pretty convincing when she says
she's not however if we watch the full
clip she does state that she knows who
is in The Fantastic Four confirming the
Fantastic Four members have been cast
together and then the next day I was
somehow in Fantastic Four I am not in
Fantastic Four but I know who is
[Applause]
but I don't want to get in trouble with
the mouse so none of you will find out
Patrick Stewart we will find out in due
course now right away I just want to
kind of point out the irony in this
because Patrick Stewart is sitting right
next to her and of course he is Marvel
royalty he is Professor X from the first
X-Men films ever and Not only was he in
the fox Universe he did of course make
his way into the MCU in Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness so I do
find this kind of funny that this is the
topic as Patrick Stewart Sir Patrick
Stewart Professor X is sitting right
next to her but the really important
thing about this clip is that Mila Kunis
confirms that the Fantastic Four have
been cast because she says that she
knows who's in the movie so if she knows
who's in the movie for sure then the
Fantastic Four members have been cast
already or at least some of them now two
people instantly come to my mind when I
hear this because they are super close
with Mila Kunis and they both have been
mentioned to be in the running to play
Fantastic Four cast members and these
members are Sue storm and the thing now
there was a rumor going around that Mila
Kunis could actually be playing the
thing and I don't think this is going to
be true at all I think that one is
simply just a rumor there's really no
reason to do that doesn't mean they
won't do it but I highly doubt it Kevin
feige really cares about this project
and I think he's gonna want it to be
pretty comic accurate and if that is the
case then Mila Kunis should not be
playing the thing no offense to her I
love her I'd be fine with her playing
suit but please not the thing but one of
her best friends someone she's really
close to is Kristen Bell and I also
personally really love her the good
place is one of my favorite shows she's
amazing in it and both her and Mila
Kunis are in Forgetting Sarah Marshall
and that movie's hilarious and they are
both amazing in that as well so since
the two of them are close and actual
friends it is possible that she could be
playing Sue storm of the MCU now clearly
Mila Kunis and Matt shackman met we have
pictures of the meeting and maybe it was
to talk about a possible role in The
Fantastic Four they could have had that
conversation and maybe it just didn't
work out but Mila Kunis could have
recommended her friend Kristen Bell now
when the news broke out or I should say
the rumor broke out that Kristen Bell
could possibly be in the running to play
Sue storm of the Fantastic Four I was
actually pretty excited about this and
something that's really interesting and
kind of great about Kristen Bell is that
although she's 42 years old right now
they can definitely make her look a lot
younger say if they want to make Reed
Richards in his mid-40s that is very
easily done because Kristen Bell does
not look like she's in her 40s and
there's always been a noticeable age
difference between Reed Richards and Sue
storm when the Fantastic Four first
debuted Stan Lee eventually confirmed
that Reed and Ben were in their late 30s
whereas Sue was in her 20s and Johnny
Storm had just turned 16. now they would
later go on to kind of retcon this a
little bit because while somebody in
their 30s dating somebody in their 20s
is no big deal the comics showed that
Sue met Reed when she was 11 and he was
21. so there was a little bit of an
issue with that so they eventually
retconned how old she was when they met
but there's always been that noticeable
age difference so if they were looking
to make sue in her 30s and read in his
40s it's possible with Kristen Bell and
it makes sense because what we've heard
about the movie so far is that this
isn't going to be an origin story and
that it's going to take place when the
Fantastic Four are kind of already
established some insiders like Daniel
rpk even state that they're already
going to have kids when we see them in
the Fantastic Four movie this could mean
that Sue storm could be in her late 20s
or in her 30s and Reed Richards could be
in his late 30s or in the 40s so Kristen
Bell fits right in with what they want
now as far as Mila Kunis's friend who
could play the thing that person also
comes from Forgetting Sarah Marshall and
that is Jason Segal he was one of the
first persons rumored to be in the
running for the thing when all of these
rumors and news first started breaking
out way back a few years ago when Kevin
feige first announced that the Fantastic
Four was official actually in
development rumors came to surface and
he was one of the first people mentioned
and people actually really kind of like
this idea because Jason Segal is really
tall as it is and he's not jacked but
you don't have to be jacked to play the
thing they're gonna give him a suit it's
gonna be Prosthetics he's gonna have a
big rock suit or maybe it's going to be
CGI but the tallness definitely helps
and he's very close with Mila Kunis so
perhaps she even threw his name out
there for the thing when she met with
Matt shackman but here is another big
thing about Jason Segal he's Jewish he
was raised Jewish had a bar mitzvah went
to Hebrew school and the thing is Ben
Grimm is Jewish in the comics and we've
heard rumors again just rumors that
Marvel Studios wants to be actually very
comic accurate with the Fantastic Four
which I hope is true and in that they
want to get a Jewish actor to play Ben
Grimm because he's Jewish another big
thing is that Jason Segal is really
funny and will often times get comedic
relief from the thing Ben Grimm but at
the same time he's got some serious
acting chops he's a very very good actor
he can't do comedy but he's played many
serious roles throughout his career and
if they are looking for the Fantastic
Four to have great chemistry with each
other which they obviously are well
Kristen Bell if she plays Sue storm
would have great chemistry with Jason
Sigel if you played the thing they've
already acted together and the movie was
fantastic so when it comes to Mila Kunis
stating that she knows who is playing
the Fantastic Four this is great because
it tells us again that it's confirmed
the Fantastic Four at least some members
have been officially cast and it also
lets us speculate a little bit about who
it could possibly be because she clearly
knows them or Matt shackman maybe just
told her if she was in the running for
Sue they could have said well hey here's
who we got for Mr Fantastic the thing
Johnny Storm do you think you'd work
well with them that's always a
possibility and it's also a possibility
that they're her friends so she knows
whatever it may be we are super excited
to find out who has been cast in The
Fantastic Four film to play the actual
Fantastic Four team since it does seem
confirmed that they've been cast it
looks like we should be hearing about it
relatively soon fingers crossed on that
one in the meantime let me know down
below what you would think about Kristen
Bell playing Sue storm and Jason Sigel
playing the thing let us know in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on the latest MCU news and
leave a comment so you can enter our
giveaway for a chance to win a PS5 Xbox
series X some Marvel Legends items or
some DC items winner gets to choose and
we're picking a winner at the end of the
month only one day left you can also
follow us on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching wolf wolf
foreign